hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
in Chapter 6 of the Proust loggia Anselm
first raises a puzzle which he will
consider at multiple times throughout
his works and which is a quite common
one raised over and over again through
the centuries by many people even down
to the present and in Chapter seven he's
going to provide a full analysis of this
problem one that I think could be quite
useful for again for many people in the
present so the puzzle is one about
divine omnipotence and he doesn't raise
any silly questions I can God create a
stone so heavy that he can't lift it
it's more of a broad consideration how
do how is it that God who we say is
omnipotent is really an impotent
when there's things that he can't do we
don't have to come up with conundrums
like imaginary stones we can point to
things that we human beings seem to be
able to do and say well why can't God do
that if God is omnipotent
maybe his immittance is really in some
respects founded or it's a lack of power
so what can't God do Anselm gives you
three
examples here but then he raises the
possibility of all sorts of others and
so we could consider some other examples
as well God he says cannot be corrupted
that is he can't break down he is what
he is and that's it as a matter of fact
and some will say that God is perfectly
simple God doesn't change God exists
from eternity and you know all of those
things seem pretty fixed don't they so
what kind of God is it if he or it
whatever God is can't sort of you know
change the the scheme of the universe or
change his own mind about things that
seems to be a bit of a problem being
corrupted you know God can't break it
down God doesn't have any parts but God
can't become less powerful or you know
forget things or anything along those
lines you also can't tell lies that
seems to be a really big restriction
doesn't it God can't you know come up
with a false story and and give it to
somebody else it seems like being able
to tell a lie would actually be a power
wouldn't it if I tell you that I'm 50
years old right now which will be true
before too long when I'm actually 48
right now I'm telling you a lie
especially if I'm doing it to deceive an
Psalms notion of Lies is fairly broad we
could say but that's a topic for another
time God also can't exercise it seems
the great power that here it whatever
God is possesses to turn what's true
into what's false or vice versa I can't
make something that's false true and the
example that Anselm uses here is being
able to undo what has been done so you
know the sorts of things that we make
into rather mundane sci-fi or fantasy
see postulates about being able to
change the past or undo things that have
been produced or made the case God can't
do that sort of thing doesn't that seem
like a real restriction of the divine
power and then he follows it up by
saying there's all sorts of similar
things fleurisima simulator
all right there's many other things in
the same way that God can't do isn't
this a problem what would those include
in the cur Deus homo he talks about God
not being able to sin God not being able
to suddenly take whatever is just and
make it unjust or vice versa and Anselm
has sort of the same standard line that
other earlier thinkers who consider this
before him has if God were to do that
then God would not be God it would not
be God that's doing that it would be
some other being but here the analysis
turns on what power really means and
what am nipa Tain's
genuinely means so the question we can
ask here that puts everything in context
is if God were able to do these sorts of
things if God could become corrupted if
God could tell lies if God could take
the truth and make it false or vice
versa would this actually be power
potentia in Latin or capacity if you
like or would this be in some way
impotence or a lack of power in potentia
the privat --iv of potentia right and if
we think about what it means to be
impotent Anselm has a very interesting
observation here if we if you think
about person right somebody who can do
these sorts of things like lie or become
unjust or sin or be corrupted somebody
can do these sorts of things is able to
do what is not good for that person and
Latin quote C be known expended what is
not expedient or what is not beneficial
for that person so the fact that I can
lie is not actually a good thing for me
because it means that there's something
damaged or lacking some deficit within
myself and it also allows us to do what
we ought not to do quote known debit and
so what if God could do these sorts of
things that would mean that God then
could actually do what's not good for
God or what does not you know suit God
you could say and what God what not to
do
Anselm goes on a little bit further and
he adds something else to this the more
he's using this this quanto tanto thing
you know there's a degree over here and
a corresponding degree over here and
that's the Latin way of expressing it
the more that a person can do these
sorts of things the more that something
else has power over that person and the
less that person has power in relation
to those things and what are they well
we just transliterate them here into
English adversity advantage they toss
right and perversity pederasty toss
right the more that these actually have
power over that person so let's take
lying for example the more that a person
is able to lie perhaps the you know they
don't really care much about the truth
the more that adversity can push them
into lying the more that they can be
compelled to lie the more that their
desires can take control over them
perversity doesn't necessarily mean as
we often think about it today sexual
perversity it means any sort of turning
away or to the side from where we ought
to be so if I for example as a teacher
ought to be presenting and some in a
faithful way perversity would be
presenting an some so that it makes me
look good or something like that right
and the more that I have this seeming
capacity to do
the more that per that perversity where
adversity would actually control me
would actually be the one or the thing
or the motive deciding for me pushing me
in certain ways so I'm not really
powerful by being able to do these
things as a matter of fact being able to
do these things is a sign of the lack of
power and so Anselm says we really need
to analyze this idea this term that we
throw around so easily potentia or power
if we want to understand omnipotent SIA
the power to do all then we need to
first understand what power is and he
actually devotes a lot of space to that
in other works but what we have here is
a nice discussion where he says that we
will often use words improperly as for
example when we use to be for not to be
or to do for not to do or for to do
nothing so he says we often say to
someone who denies that something exists
it is as you say it we use this word for
non being for being right or reverse and
we confuse ourselves in a way because
we're talking about something that isn't
the case as if it is the case so that's
one way we do that he also says we say
the man is sitting just as we say that
man is doing something sitting is not
really doing it's a not doing something
else not standing or we say the man is
resting just as we say the man is doing
something to rest is to do nothing
so then anthem says in the same way so
he's drawing an analogy here when
someone is said to have the power the
potentia when somebody said to have the
power of doing something right or
suffering something which is not to his
advantage which is not suitable to him
or which you ought not to do
then by power what we really mean is a
lack of power and AM impotence a most of
nipa tents but rather impotence an imp
intense in relation to something else
which is going to be driving us and
calling the shots something else is more
powerful than us so it's not strictly
speaking correct to say that we are
powerful by being able to do these
things rather we are able to be
subjected to the power of other things
that then has us doing these sorts of
things like lying or making true things
into false which doesn't always have to
be about changing the past right it
could be about changing ourselves as
true human beings and too depraved human
beings and we could go on and on and on
none of those things are fitting for God
and as a matter of fact it wouldn't be
am impotent to be able to do any of
those things so what this leads us to is
the realization that we actually have
the notion of am impotence wrong and
that's why we have this puzzle if we see
things correctly as an Psalm says then
we conclude that God is more truly
omnipotent and uses that term various
their God is really am impotent not just
the sort of simplistic conception of
omnipotence that we had in our head
before we carried out this analysis so
this allows that puzzle to be at least
explained if not necessarily dispelled
and you could take other examples and
similarly apply this same line of
reasoning to that and this helps Ansem
to say how god genuinely is omnipotent
you